today we're going to be talking about
transfer learning which we didn't quite
have time to get to last time and in
particular we'll talk about the problem
formulation
and fine-tuning which is a very
successful and popular approach to
transfer learning
and then we'll start diving into metal
learning
we'll talk about the problem formulation
a general recipe of metal learning
algorithms
one class of approaches which i call
black box adaptation approaches
plenty of time we'll also
go through a case study of gpt-3 which
can be viewed as a black box metal
learner
and then by the end of the lecture
hopefully you'll be able to understand
the differences between multitask
learning transfer learning and meta
learning some of the basics of transfer
learning as well as the training setup
for future learning algorithms and how
to implement black box metal learning
techniques which you'll be doing in the
first homework
great so let's get started uh with
transfer learning
so i
recall last time we talked we went over
multitask learning and the goal of the
multi-task learning problem is to solve
multiple tasks at once so you have some
number of tasks and maybe t tasks you
have a data set for each tasks and
you're trying to learn a single model
with parameters theta
that can solve those tasks and some of
these parameters might be shared some of
them might be
might be actually not shared across
tasks the goal is just to be able to do
well
on the different tasks on all the tasks
that you're given
given the data set
now what does transfer look look like
what does transfer learning look like in
comparison to this
so
the goal of transfer learning is to
solve
a target task which i'll denote as
task b after solving a source task task
a
and in particular the goal here is to
kind of transfer some knowledge that you
learned that you kind of acquired when
learning task a
when trying uh to solve task b
and one kind of key assumption that
transfer learning methods typically make
is that you can't actually access the
data for task a during this transfer
process
so you basically have to learn something
about task a then you can no longer
access that data but you can access the
knowledge that you've learned when
trying to solve task b
um and so transfer learning is actually
a valid solution to multitask learning
you could learn one task and then learn
don't learn the next task but not vice
versa because you um multitask learning
assumes that you have
all of the data available when you're
solving them
um so a question for you uh to get
started for today you can answer and
chat or raise your hand
what are some problems or applications
where transfer learning might make sense
uh but where multitask learning might
not make sense
any ideas or thoughts
i'm sorry yeah i actually had a question
so can you
use the data from problem for task
[Music]
so kind of specifically you assume that
you've learned something about task a
you have that knowledge and then you
also have a data set from task b and you
want to leverage both your previous
knowledge and the data from task b
to learn a model for task b
uh
training a robot to follow instructions
in one house and then getting it to all
instructions in another house
yeah that's a good example so maybe the
robot a robot has learned to do one task
in one house and now you want to kind of
transfer what's learned to that towards
a new task but you don't want to have to
kind of retrain it on that previous
house you just want it to do well in the
next house
do you also have thoughts
yeah i'm just going to say something
similar transferring a robot in a
simulated
great yeah so maybe you have you've
trained something in simulation you've
learned something about kind of physics
or how to perform a task and then you
want to uh kind of leverage that
knowledge when when learning something
in the real world but maybe you don't
want to have to retrain on simulation
throughout the process because you
really care about
what you really care about learning
something in the real world and not
learning something in simulation
looking at the chat there's also um
some thoughts about kind of transferring
from one hospital to another hospital
when you're looking at kind of medical
data you may not be able to access the
previous hospitals images but you want
to be able to kind of leverage what you
learn there
um
also things like
transferring from learning a simpler
task like picking up the vlog to a
harder task like picking up an irregular
shaped object
uh
personalization personalization will
actually i think actually falls well
within the metal learning context and
we'll potentially talk a bit about that
later
um
yeah and then another example is when
you have a small amount of data for task
b and task a and b are similar
also image style transfer
and some other settings so these are all
good examples
uh and then yeah another example is like
maybe you don't have limit you have kind
of limited compute power and so you
don't want to have to keep on training
on task a when transferring to task b
so
yeah what i wrote on the slide first is
kind of something that that
you guys came up with which is if
this data set d a is very large and you
only have kind of a limited compute
budget then you don't want to have to
retain and retrain on that data set when
transferring to the second task
another example is we don't care about
solving both task a and task b
simultaneously you only care about
really the thing that you're
transferring to uh the cinder real
example is like one good example of this
where you don't really ultimately care
about getting a policy that works in
simulation you care more about solving
the target task
and in this case it's it's fine to kind
of discard what you had learned from
tasking and just try to use that
knowledge when learning task b
okay um and then also i guess one thing
that isn't here is if if there's some
issue with kind of being able to access
the data set from task a then this is
also a scenario where that might make
sense
okay um yeah and then there's also a
question in the chat about is there any
kind of differential privacy concerns
when it comes to transfer learning or is
inferring the data to train the neural
network difficult enough to render this
irrelevant um this is actually a really
good question if one of the reasons why
you're using transfer learning is
because you have to throw away your data
set dda
um because you just like for privacy
reasons or something else
then um there are potentially concerns
about well maybe you're throwing away
the data set a but you're still
retaining the model that was trained on
da and you may actually be able to
reconstruct the data in a and private
information in a from that model
and so in those contexts when you do
care about privacy of the of things in
the source task then you do want to
think about whether it is actually
possible to reconstruct that data from
the model itself
and
and think carefully about that
okay
so
this is kind of the transfer learning
problem statement and how it differs
with multitask learning
and the really the most uh
really the most prevalent approach to
transfer learning is something that's
called fine tuning
especially within neural networks and
deep learning
so the way that fine tuning works is you
assume that you have some set of
parameters that are pre-trained on
a data set that the source data set da
and then you run gradient descent using
the
using the training data for the new task
test b
so this is kind of the
the data corresponding to task b or at
least the training data quartz file into
tusky
and typically you don't just one
run one gradient step you typically run
many gradient steps on this new new task
for this new data set
so that's that's it it's quite simple uh
and it actually works
quite well uh in a number of different
instances especially when
there's a lot of kind of rich
information and knowledge in your source
data set ga
so for example if you pre-train on
imagenet this is what this kind of row
is right here
and then fine tune on the pascal data
set and the sun data set
you get these are kind of other image
classification benchmarks that are a bit
different uh you get 58 percent and 52
accuracy respectively whereas if you
instead initialize your net your network
weights randomly you get 41 and 35
so essentially all of the knowledge
coming from images is quite helpful for
getting a higher accuracy on these
downstream data sets in comparison to a
randomly initialized neural network
um one question is well okay
say i won't have some downstream tests
that i want to be able to transfer to
what are some good data sets for
pre-training
and where might i get pre-trained
parameters uh imagenet classification
has been one that's kind of been proven
time and time again that's been quite
helpful especially for downstream image
based tasks even when your your target
task
is not actually
a natural image classification task so
people have shown that image that
classification has been helpful for
depth images for example
and other kinds of other kinds of
non-natural images
uh another kind of popular example for
pre-training is using models language
models that are trained on very large
language corpora uh
examples of those are burt and language
models and we'll kind of show some
results on that on the next slide
and then another kind of just generally
generally popular especially actually
popular
um
maybe in the 90s or so was actually to
use unsupervised learning techniques to
get pre-trained parameters and then
fine-tune from that
unsupervised learning techniques like
auto encoders for example
and uh really just kind of whatever
large and diverse dataset you might have
lying around can be
quite helpful for pre-training
when you want to transfer the
information that large and diverse data
set to your downstream task
lastly a lot of these pre-trained models
are often available online so you don't
actually have to
even download the data set and train on
that data set you can typically just
download a pre-trained model from the
internet and then fine-tune that model
on the task that you care about
okay
and then
fine-tuning in general is a bit of an
art there's a lot of different design
decisions that go into it with regard to
which weights you choose to run gradient
descent on um how you set the learning
rate and so forth
and unfortunately there hasn't really
been
any kind of
science behind what happens when you
choose these different design choices
but there are some common practices so
it's common to fine-tune with a smaller
learning rate so that you don't kind of
destroy what is in the pre-trained
network with a larger learning rate
it's also common to have a smaller
learning rate for the earlier layers
because often the earlier layers in the
network have more general purpose
features like edge detectors in image
classification network
it's also common to even freeze early
earlier layers setting their learning
rate to zero and then potentially
gradually unfreeze them until you train
once you train the later parts of the
network effectively
sometimes you also re-initialize the
last layer if you want that to kind of
learn quickly and adapt quickly to your
new task
um and then in all these cases you can
search over very these various design
choices and hyper parameters with cross
validation on your downstream target
task
and then finally different architectures
matter a lot so for example a network
architecture called residual networks or
resnets tend to fine-tune more quickly
simply because it's easier for gradients
to pass through all of the network
compared to some other architectures
okay so any kind of questions on this
on kind of
fine tuning and how it works
there's a question from
is pre-trading and unsupervised learning
setting performing better than imagenet
um
this is a good question i think that in
general
as of a year ago i know that imagenet
was doing better i know that people have
been really actually most recently
pushing on on supervised learning
techniques and also what's called
semi-supervised learning
um
in general i think that imagenet has
been more successful but there i think
there have been some recent results that
have shown uh promise and unsupervised
learning approaches approaching uh
pre-training on imagenet
do you have a question
yeah can you just talk a little more
about
search or hyper parameters
how would we do that in practice
yeah so
one kind of uh often
one kind of
reasonable way to do that in practice is
to choose some hyper parameters that you
think might be reasonable
try them out run
run fine tuning with those hyper
parameters and then see what the
validation performance is uh on a held
out validation set
uh for some different choices then for
the choice that works the best you
either choose that or maybe refine them
even further there are also more
automated techniques for this such as
grid search random search where you kind
of sample
um
sample values within some range for all
of the hyper parameters
and that can if you have a fair amount
of compute then that can also be an
effective way to choose hyper grammars
and then lastly there's also techniques
invasion optimization that try to
optimize the hyperparameters for you
i'm not sure if i pronounce that right
yeah you got it right
so i i have this basic question about
transfer learning so some of the
examples
um make sense so like uh on the on the
language corporate one language uh has
it and then uh to transfer knowing the
other language but some of the examples
um previously stated like um robot
motion in one setting versus the other
how do you uh how do i think about
transfer learning versus generalization
because like in in that case i couldn't
i also think that if my body was
you know generalized enough that it
would be able to learn in a different
setting and i shouldn't
need to fine-tune my last layer
a good question
so
um it's possible that you'd be that the
network the parameters data themselves
will just generalize to a new setting if
your target task is close enough to the
tasks that you pre-trained on
um
and if if that is you could just kind of
just test it and see if it works and if
it works then you don't actually need to
do any fine tuning uh and that's what's
called zero shot generalization in the
sense that you don't you're basically
generalizing to this new context without
any new data points
and then if that doesn't work then fine
tuning is usually kind of the next step
that you can use to try to
be able to do well in that new setting
thanks
so this is i guess a specific question
for
large language models
in that i've read a few papers that have
kind of tried to fine-tune or gpt-2 for
example on new data set
and rather than kind of adopting these
common practices they start with a
learning rate that's near zero
uh amp it up to some large values and
bring it back down
is there any intuition for why that's a
[Music]
yeah so i actually haven't um read those
papers myself
i
i guess i don't have any good intuition
for that um at least off the top of my
head for why that might make sense i
think that in general it makes sense for
it to have a larger learning rate for
the later layers because those are
probably the things that need to change
the most um so maybe when you amp it up
it's really focusing on those later
layers and then
after that and general decaying your
learning rate makes a lot of sense
but i'm not sure
uh kind of ramping up the learning rate
to be higher for the earlier layers
seems like it could also have a
detrimental effect so i'm not sure
exactly what the intuition for that is
okay
hi yeah uh my question was about um like
dimensionality and how that ties into
transfer lighting like for example if
you're um do a computer vision right
like you have your set um kernel sizes
but the images are going to be
like
if you're adapting to a new data set you
could just have completely different
size images and like fewer channels or
something and like so i guess i was
wondering what your intuition was for
like let's say you're you're jumping to
dsfb which has
images have like
like half a number of channels but like
twice the actual resolution
like dude um i guess how does that tie
into how you decide to freeze certain
layers or like reinitialize certain
layers
yeah so one thing that you could do um
when handling
images of different dimensions when you
want to kind of fine-tune two images
with a different dimension is to
well one obvious thing you could do is
just to resize it to the dimension
that's the same as what the pre-trained
uh model was trained on
um but that
that may be discarding information um or
it may be your images are smaller and
you don't have a good way to up sample
them
um
i think the most important thing to do
is to make sure that if you're
especially if you're using smaller
images to make sure that when you your
network is kind of decreasing the
dimensionality of the features that they
don't become too small
if you need to have higher resolution
for example
then
the default way to kind of pool or
dimensionality
may not actually work for the smaller
images that you're transferring to
beyond that um
i think that in some ways this is kind
of a design another um design choice to
see if it it works for the higher
resolution images or not
um
i don't think that there's any work that
really studies us systematically
okay then one more question from
or sorry
yeah
also i want to ask what size do we
expect for the new data set so can we
come into transfer learning for future
learning and if we can like whatever
some practices he recommends
yeah that's a great question and
actually kind of uh transitions nicely
into the next slide so um these plots
are actually from pre-training with a
language model
kind of omfit is the name of this paper
which is unsupervised language model and
then fine tuning
and what these plots are showing is that
on the x-axis is the number of training
examples in your target task so
on the right you have kind of a larger
target data set on the left you have a
smaller target data set and what you see
is that the validation error rate on
your target task
goes down as you have more data so if
you have more data from your target task
then these methods
then kind of fine tuning works better
and specifically the orange and the
green curve are showing fine tuning and
the blue curve is showing training from
scratch
but if the number of training examples
is really small like if you only have
100 training examples then fine tuning
isn't as successful with a substantially
higher validation error rate than if you
had many more examples
so kind of the overall takeaway here is
that fine-tuning doesn't work
quite as well when you have very small
target task data sets uh it's most
successful when you have kind of a more
moderate size data set but you don't
still don't need something as large as
imagenet for example with millions of
examples
um and so this is also kind of where
metal learning can come in
and
uh and kind of allow you to be able to
generalize better when you have a very
small amount of data and so that's what
we'll talk about next
do you have a question
yes i think that's right
[Music]
yeah so what i mean by that is that when
you have 100 examples
your validation error rate for
orange and green is around 30 to 40
whereas if you have say a thousand
examples then your validation error rate
is closer to 10 on this data set which
is the the track six data set and you
see kind of a similar trend and ideally
we'd like to take this kind of this
performance when you have only 100
training examples and get it closer to
um closer to the kind of level that we
can perform if you have more data
that said it is still doing better than
scratch
when you have small amounts of data so
there's still a big improvement there
which is good
okay
so now let's talk a bit about metal
learning and we'll start by talking
about the problem formulation um and
i guess a disclaimer is that i'll cover
the middle learning problem statement
that we'll consider in this class
which is basically the problem statement
that the metal learning algorithm
algorithms that we'll discuss will
solve but there are other forms of
meta-learning algorithms that
solve a different problem statement
so that's kind of i guess a disclaimer
there's a lot of things that people have
called metal learning um this is what
will be kind of this is the problem
statement that we'll be considering in
this course
uh and to start off i think there's in
many ways two ways to view metal
learning algorithms there is a more
mechanistic view and there's a more of a
probabilistic view
in the mechanistic view you could view
metal learning as essentially a deep
neural network that can read in data
sets and learn from those data sets to
make predictions for new data points
and training the network itself uses a
data set of data sets for a metadata set
which itself
consists of many data sets
and each data set is for a different
task
this is sort of like the mechanistic
view that we'll talk about
and then the probabilistic view of this
is you can view metal learning as trying
to extract prior knowledge from a set of
tasks
that allows for efficient learning of
new tasks
and specifically learning a new task
uses this prior and a small training
data set to infer the most likely
posterior parameters
um there's kind of these two views i
think are actually both quite
interesting and useful
uh
today we're going to focus primarily on
the mechanistic view because i think
it's a little bit easier
to understand especially from the
standpoint of implementing these
algorithms
but we will talk about the probabilistic
view when we talk about bayesian metal
learning algorithms and explicitly
connect these metal learning algorithms
to graphical models and learning priors
over parameters in those graphical
models
okay
um so
when talking about um
metal learning in the middle learning
problem statement i'd like to first
start with an example
so uh and specifically we'll look at a
few shot image classification example uh
and
the goal of this fuchsia image
classification problem will be
the following
given one example of five different
classes
this essentially have a little mini
training data set with five examples
your goal is to classify new examples
among the five classes that are in the
training data set
um so essentially your goal is to learn
from five data points to
identify and classify new examples
this is analogous to the few shot
learning problem that you did in the
first lecture with the different
paintings where you were trying to
classify from six examples which painter
painted the test
image
so this is an example of a few shot
learning problem and this is kind of the
the problem that metal learning tries to
solve uh or at least few shot by
learning algorithms try to solve
and the way that they do this is they
they aren't going to start from scratch
if you were starting from scratch you
wouldn't be able to train on this kind
of tiny data set of five examples of
course
and so what metal learning algorithms
try to do is like transfer learning they
assume that they have some previous data
and in particular
in this example they assume that they
have previous data of other image
classes
and that data will be structured
just like
what we see at last time it will be
structured into train sets and test sets
and we'll kind of construct these
training sets and these these testing
sets for many different image
classification tasks
these will be
constructed among a large number of
training classes uh which will be
different from the classes that are used
at test time
and the goal would be is to essentially
figure out to
create a model such that after it sees
this training data set on the left it
can effectively classify new examples
in the test set on the right
so it's essentially learning how to
learn each of these image classification
tasks
and then once you kind of
learn how to learn these different tasks
in the meta training set
then at meta testing when you're given
this new
viewshot learning problem you'll be
prepared to solve it because you've
solved many other few shot learning
problems
uh so this is kind of a new task and it
also has a training set and a test set
uh and you can also so this is kind of
one example of a metal learning problem
where you have these different tasks and
each task corresponds to an image
classification task
but you can replace image classification
with different regression tasks you can
replace it with language generation
tasks you can replace it with robotic
skill learning tasks
really any kind of machine learning
problem can be filled
you can replace these tasks with
so that's kind of an example and more
concretely the meta learning problem is
the following
given data from n different tasks your
goal is to quickly solve a new task
given a small data set for that new task
so maybe the data set
is
d-test
uh and one of the key assumptions here
that we're going to use is that the meta
training tasks and the meta test tasks
are drawn iid from the same task
distribution
so
for example there'll be some
distribution over task ski
all of your
meta training tasks task 1 through task
n are drawn from that distribution as
well as your test task is also drawn
from that distribution
and this assumption is really important
because
that means that after we've kind of
trained on this set of tasks when we're
given a new task we can expect that
we'll generalize
under the same principles of kind of iid
training in supervised learning
okay
um and then like before
like
like multitask learning and transfer
learning the tasks must share some
structure so if this distribution p is
the distribution over all possible tasks
and you're just drawing random tasks
from it there's no structure that you
can latch on to
to learn the new test task more quickly
and instead what metal learning aims to
do is to kind of find the common
structure among all of the training
tasks and leverage that structure when
learning the new task so that it can
learn it with less data than if it were
training from scratch
so there are some questions on how this
relates to multitask learning and meta
learning
and
the kind of main difference is that in
multitask learning you would be given
data from end tasks and you wanted to
solve those end tasks you don't really
care about solving a new task
leveraging that experience whereas in
metal learning your goal is to
potentially solve those end tasks but
most importantly be able to quickly
solve a new task with a small amount of
data
okay
what do the different tasks correspond
to
they can correspond to a lot of the
things that we were talking about before
so they can correspond to recognizing
handwritten digits from different
languages you'll be using
uh you'll be looking at handwritten
digits that look like this and trying to
classify
uh
handwritten digits from a new language
after seeing data from a number of
different languages you'll also be
looking um you can also have kind of a
spam filter for different users and your
goal is to kind of given a new user and
a little bit of data from that new user
can you learn a good spam filter for
that user
you may be interested in looking at
classifying species species from
different regions of the world maybe you
have a lot of data from a range of
different regions but then you're given
a little bit of data for a new region
you want to be able to learn a good
classifier for that new region
from a small amount of data
and then lastly you can also correspond
to a robot performing different tasks
maybe the robot has learned 50 different
tasks before and it wants to learn
kind of add a new task to its repertoire
from a small amount of data this is
another way to do that
okay
now one other natural question is how
many tasks do you need what should the
value of n be
uh the more the better uh in many ways
uh kind of this is analogous to having
more data in machine learning if you
have more tasks then you'll be able to
potentially do better on a new held out
task
one thing that's different though is
that per task you don't necessarily need
a lot of data
you just want to have a lot of tasks to
cover a broader distribution
okay
any questions on this before we go over
some terminology
uh yeah my question is a few slides back
it was um yeah right there um
okay so
when it's classifying the
new examples is it just giving it like
one uh like is it
since it can't tell us whether it's like
a lion or a bull it will just give us
like a one or zero that corresponds to
the training data
like it
so yeah so at minute test time you'll be
given
these five images in green and you'll
also be given kind of labels associated
with each of these images
zero one two three four and then your
goal will be
given these kind of test images you want
um you wanna learn a classifier that
basically tells you that this line
corresponds to a label of two and this
bowl corresponds to a label of four
make sense thanks
[Music]
should be sufficient or like you need
like 25 30 or like minimum number of
times
yeah that's a good question um
i would say more than one uh
uh and i think that basically the more
tasks you have the more effective it
will be at generalizing to a new task if
you only have a few tasks then it may
not be able to kind of generalize and
kind of find the common structure from
those tasks in a way that allows you to
um do well
but really more than one is the
is kind of what it looks like and if you
only have one task that looks a lot like
transfer
learning minimum we can think of okay
this might be
like 10
[Music]
yeah yeah and then in the homework
you'll be looking at the omniglot data
set which actually allows you to
construct on the order of a thousand
tasks
um but i've also seen metal learning be
successful when you only have like maybe
50 tasks um or maybe even a little bit
less than that
so uh question like mighty task learning
what is the maximum number of tasks
i can see that my testing you can do at
least two tasks but like how maximum you
can go and multitask learning right
where you can start
yeah it really depends on the problem
setting uh like how many tasks you start
seeing benefits or not um
yeah it kind of yeah it's really problem
dependent
it looks like there is a also a
clarification question in the chat which
is what's the difference between x test
and d test um i'm i'm kind of calling
this uh these examples x test and then
these are within some data set
uh d-test
uh so
yeah so this is basically
um
[Music]
well yeah so for this task for example i
would call this kind of
d train for task one
and d test for task one
and
uh
yeah i think that answers the question
um yeah so um i guess just to understand
the idea of like meta in this
uh
like what we're trying to do is it like
we have um
like one task or like a multiple tasks
which is like do you want into there and
then like is it we give it the meta
which is these five images and then we
have the input which is the those two
images to classify and then it needs to
use that matter or like refer to that to
like make our prediction is that kind of
like where the
the meta time is
like
so we'll get a better understanding of
kind of
uh
why it necessarily corresponds to by
learning when we talk about algorithms
but one one perspective that you could
take here is that like for this task for
each task for example you're trying to
learn from a data set and be able to
generalize to
uh the test data set so each each of
these tasks corresponds to a learning
problem
and then
when you're considering all of these
tasks uh and trying to be able to
quickly learn from
uh any of these training data sets then
you're essentially learning how to learn
each of these tasks
uh and so that's sort of where metal
learning comes from
okay so when you say like we want to
like be able to like learn a new task
quickly is that like so a new task would
be like uh if we get like uh image from
each of those classes and then like we
sample some random two images from like
any of the classic that would be like a
new task
like
exactly so this is like this corresponds
to a new task and you
uh your goal at test time is to learn
this new task with this small data set
uh okay yeah got it thank you
all right uh so i heard in nlp the
learning hasn't converged in terms of
some past x4 and natural equations so is
it true for our
vision as well where the learning is
because
you can use it's just not converge you
can just include as much as many tasks
as much later for each task
so are you asking
if you include more tasks like like
i guess i'm gonna try to understand the
question but the question is if you just
yeah um i think this is a riff of a
previous question where um how you know
the maximum number so to speak has a
learning converges
yeah so i think that um
yeah the question is kind of like what
is the maximum number of tasks until you
really start seeing that it converge um
in the omniglot data set which we'll
talk a bit more about later where you
have around a thousand tasks i think in
that setting the validation
performance starts to converge towards
the trading performance and that's a
setting where
it does seem like you have enough tasks
in that uh setting then again it is also
still very problem dependent if you have
a very broad data distribution then
you'll need more tasks to cover that
whereas if you have a very narrow
task distribution then you may not
actually need a very large number of
tasks to adequately cover that
um i'll go through i want to kind of
quickly also go through a bit of
terminology since this may also answer
some of the questions and then i'll take
some more questions
so
um
as i mentioned before kind of each of
these green
boxes correspond to training data sets
for individual tasks so this might be
maybe this is task i
then this box corresponds to the
training set for that task i
and this
red box corresponds to the test data set
for that task
um
this is kind of the training and test
data sets are distinct from what's
called meta training and meta testing so
in many ways you're actually going to be
using these individual meta training
test task data sets
or sorry um the test data sets for
different mediterranean tasks you'll be
using this and actually training with
these during the mediterranean process
uh and sometimes a distinct to kind of
make a better distinction between
metatrading and meta-testing and
training and testing people instead call
each of these green boxes the support
set and the red box is the query set
um and we'll probably use both of them
interchangeably although in practice i
think i'll typically use the training
set in the test set a bit more
frequently
and then uh when we talk about fu shot
learning
uh or k shot learning like one shot
learning five shot learning what this
means is that we're gonna be learning
with k examples
per class
and
or if we're in a regression scenario
we're going to be using k total training
examples
for learning
so kind of k shot means you'll be using
k examples
uh and then
if you're doing anyway classification
then you're choosing between
n classes so you're basically
classifying among end things
so one kind of question for you based on
this terminology is in this above
example
what would the values of k
and n be
and you can answer you can ask answer
this in chat
so k is the number of examples per class
and n is the
number of classes
great so it looks like people are
entering the
correct answer which is k equals one and
n equals five for this above example
because we have one example for five
different classes
typically the value of one and the value
of k and n you often keep it consistent
among metatrading and meta testing but
you could also train on a larger number
of n
or variable
k
and then test it on on variable k and
variable n
so there is like fuchsia learning um is
it does that mean basically that um like
when k is small like it does better or
something i i don't know i'm just
curious if you can talk about that a
little bit
yeah so the problem with future learning
is basically when you want to learn with
a small amount of data um so basically
when k is when k is small then you have
a small data set you want to learn from
a few examples
okay uh
do you have a question
yeah um is there some more formal
definition of what a task distribution
is like do they have to have common
classes or
what's what's the definition of a task
distribution
yeah um
i think that there isn't really a
formal definition of the distribution
over tasks i guess before i gave a
formal distribution of what a task is
which corresponds to the kind of the
data generating distributions of
basically
p of x
and p of y given x
and you could potentially these are kind
of the true distributions underlying the
data and you could view
um
maybe these uh
true distributions are parameterized by
phi in some way and then you could view
formally view a distribution over tasks
as being equivalent to a distribution
over the parameters of those data
generating distributions
um
in general though it's it's a bit tricky
to think about sometimes because
uh
sometimes these data-generating
distributions aren't even necessarily
necessarily have a parametric form um
and
so it's it's a bit tricky and it's a
little bit dependent on the particular
domain that you're in
uh one example of
where you can parameterize a task
distribution is maybe different tasks
correspond to different sinusoids where
maybe
they're all different a family of
sinusoid functions where you're trying
to regress to the value of the sinusoid
given the x value
um and then maybe the parameters would
correspond to like the amplitude of
different sinusoids or the phase of
different sinusoids and there you might
actually be able to explicitly represent
the distribution over the data
generating parameters
but in practice it's a bit tricky to do
that because we don't really know the
parameters underlying the image
formation process for example
right so kind of the definition of
potassium region can be as brown as
possible like if there is a fast
distribution that includes all the time
possible
um
i guess it's not clear um you could have
something that conceivably covers all
the tasks possible
but then that may
if p of x is like truly random then they
might that might not actually be that
useful or interesting because typically
for like image classification for
example we're interested in
natural images and so p of x we would
want to kind of cover the kind of
to cover the
distribution over natural images and not
include random noise or white noise for
example all right
hi um i have a general question um i
wonder what uh how the
how the metal learning
is robust or uh in some extent compared
to other conventional supervised
learning um
for
example um if there are some wrongly
labeled images in the image
classification example
yeah so i think it's going to depend on
the
on the algorithm that you use i think
the different algorithms may have
different
different robustness properties
i'm also not aware of any works that
explicitly
study that although there was actually a
course project last year that looked at
if you could essentially meditate a
model to be robust to
label noise so you could look at the
course projects from last year if you're
interested in that
okay thanks
hi um yeah i'm still trying to tease out
the difference between
metal learning and transporting
[Music]
the different concepts he said
yeah yeah so here's a summary slide that
kind of goes over it to some degree so
in transfer learning the previous data
that you're going to have will be
typically in the form of a single task
whereas in middle learning you're going
to assume actually have a stronger
assumption and assume that you have
these different tasks and that the
different tasks are drawn from the same
distribution as your downstream task
one way that you could view this is that
metal learning algorithms are actually
going to be explicitly optimizing for
the ability to learn a task within that
distribution
whereas transfer learning approaches
tend to be a bit more ad hoc and they
for example in fine tuning will just
kind of trade on one task and then fine
tune
the weights on another task
does this answer your question
um
i i guess i'm thinking
what
qualifies as something like a test being
distinct from another task
yeah i guess so yeah in the image
recognition example uh it is a good
point that basically
you could construct these tasks from a
single data set from like the imagenet
data set for example and this is
actually quite common
in the fuchsia image classification
literature
um
one thing that is important is that you
have to actually construct those tasks
rather than just having a single
monolithic task
in metal learning because you have to be
able to
and you have to construct them in a way
that it is from the same distribution as
your test task
um
but it is true that basically these
tasks could be constructed from
a data set that's quite similar to the
data set that you use for the source
task and transfer learning
all right maybe we'll move on to
hi um i have a question about some the
slide with the terminology on it
um
i'm still
i guess a little bit confused so is that
first green box um is that equal to
the sub i in the training set or is that
just one example from b sub 1 of the
training set
yeah so this first green box uh
this kind of green box right here this
would be like
d sub i for like test one so maybe i
equals one and then this whole box would
be
uh
d sub i for i equals two
does that answer your question yeah
thank you great
uh i think we'll type out her question
in the chat uh in the meantime
oh yeah uh so i was just wondering why
do the tasks have the same number of
classes like the fixed n
does it help because it doesn't look
like the classes are like similar across
the classes
so you're asking why why have a fixed
end for different tasks yes
yeah so in practice you could have a
larger um you could have kind of a
a varying end for different tasks
you do want to have a set um you do want
to have a scenario where the test task
that your test that kind of the meta
testing test has a value of n that's at
least as
kind of um there's no larger than any of
the n that you saw during training
but you could you can have variable
n thank you
uh and then
yes in the chat is task grouping
considered a challenge
uh
we see task grouping is a challenge in
multitask learning and i was reading a
recent paper that comes up with a task
grouping framework to deal with it
yeah so different tasks may be more
similar to one another like you may have
um you could construct a task
distribution that has medical images and
natural images for example and it may
actually be helpful to learn a grouping
of those tasks if you find that your
algorithm isn't finding common ground
between those two sets of tasks uh and
that yeah that's definitely um a
challenge that people have looked at
especially when you observe negative
transfer between different sets of tasks
cool and then one more question from
um what do we have what to do if we have
um varying k for each task
yeah so you can also have variance k and
we'll we'll talk about this a bit when
we talk about algorithms
so feel free to bring that up again when
we talk about algorithms i'll try to
cover it when we talk about block box
methods
okay um so let's move on to algorithms
for the sake of time so uh to recap the
problem setting i guess we went over
this slide a bit but in multitask
learning you're trying to solve multiple
tasks at once
in transfer learning you're trying to
solve a new task after solving a source
task and in meta learning you're trying
to quickly solve a new task given data
from a number of previous tasks
in both transfer learning and meta
learning it's generally impractical and
practical to access the source task for
the previous meta training tests
just because you often don't want to
retrain on that data or maybe
you don't have the space to retain all
that or just it's really slow
and in all these three settings the
tasks must share some common structure
in order to get benefit compared to just
training these tasks from scratch
okay so now let's actually talk about a
general recipe of meta-learning
algorithms and then one instantiation of
that
uh and
kind of i guess first let's talk about a
general recipe for evaluating a better
learning algorithm
uh and in particular i want to kind of
highlight the omni lot data set that
we've talked about a little bit up until
now
so the
data set has
1623 characters from 50 different
alphabets uh and here's kind of an
example of what the data looks like so
it has alphabets like hebrew bengali
greek futurama
and for each of the characters in each
of these alphabets there's 20 instances
that are handwritten
of each character
and so one thing that's interesting
about this data set is that it has
many different classes so it has more
than a thousand classes
but it only has a few examples per class
so only 20 instances per class
and in some ways this is kind of like
the transpose of mnist uh
because the mnist data set for example
has 10 classes
and it has um like a very large it's
like 1600 or something like a very large
number of instances per class
and i also think that this sort of data
set is actually more reflective of what
we see in the real world
we don't see like a thousand different
instances of forks and spoons and a
thousand different water bottles and so
forth we see much more diversity in the
objects that we see and in the words
that we see and so forth but we only see
each kind of each instance a few times
often
um so that i think is makes kind of
makes these sort of days that's quite
appealing
and the omniglot paper uh proposed by
brendan lake in 2015 actually proposes
two different um
kinds of problems both discriminative
problems where you want to classify the
character from the image as well as a
generative problem where given maybe one
or a few examples of a character you
want to generate more instances of that
character
although to date the discriminative
version has been much more popular and
used much more widely than the
generative version
and then kind of the initial few shot
learning techniques uh before this paper
and also um around the time of people
were modeling characters were actually
based off of bayesian models and
non-parametric approaches
and brendan lake showed that these
approaches can actually be these kinds
of approaches can actually be quite uh
quite good at modeling these simple
characters
but they are harder to scale towards
natural images and and kind of larger
data sets and and more complex data sets
and so that's why we'll be focusing on
more more approaches based on deep
learning in this course
uh and then beyond the beyond the
omniglot data set which in many ways is
uh actually already has
fairly saturated performance uh people
have used other image recognition data
sets like uh imagenet and different
variants of that cfar cub and sleve
uh and then
beyond
image classification there also are a
couple other benchmarks that i'll
mention in case you're interested in
using them for your course project
such as predicting the properties of
different molecules
and predicting the pose of different
objects
okay so this is kind of uh
some data sets that people have used for
evaluating my learning
algorithms and then now to start to talk
about different approaches i actually
want to present a second view on the
meta learning problem
and in particular i'll do this in
relation to supervised learning so one
way to view the supervised learning
problem is that we're given an input x
image and output y
we want to learn a model that predicts y
from x we do this with a data set
now
similar and analogously to this we can
view the meta-supervised learning
problem
as something where we're given a data
set that has k examples
and
a new data point x test
and given this we want to predict the
corresponding label for x test
and so you can view the metal learning
problem as something that essentially
takes in a data set and a new data point
learn something from that data set
that training data set and makes a
prediction
that hopefully generalizes to this new
test data point to predict y test
and the way that we do this is
analogous to supervised learning we have
data
but in this case our data corresponds to
a data set of data sets
where each data set has
more than k examples so that you can
sample k to be used in the training data
set and at least one to be used to
measure generalization here
now you might ask well we already talked
about the metal learning problem why is
this useful why are you telling me this
uh this view is actually useful because
in many ways it reduces the metal
learning problem
to figuring out how we might want to
design this function h and how we want
to optimize this function h
so
essentially kind of a general recipe for
metal learning algorithms is to choose a
form of this function that basically
takes in a data set learns something
from that data set and makes predictions
on new data points
and then second choose how to optimize
the parameters of this
uh of this learner
with respect to some
maximum likelihood objective using the
meta training data
so this is basically kind of the
the general recipe for my learning
algorithms um we'll refer to theta as
the meta parameters in the sense that
they're the kind of parameters of this
uh
learner here
um and this function will often kind of
refer to you
as the learner
in the sense that it's learning
something from a data set and applying
what it's learned to predict the label
for x test
okay
so this is the general recipe
and
really the simplest way to
instantiate this is
what i'll call black box adaptation
where the key idea is to represent to
kind of train a neural network
to represent
this learner
that takes his input a data set
and outputs
a set of parameters
and then predicts test data points with
a model with those parameters
so in some ways you can uh
i guess before it called asia learner we
could also call this a learner where
it's taking a data set and and basically
outputting a new set of parameters
analogous to how things like sgd
take a set of initial parameters and
then produce a learned model
but in this case
f isn't going to represent sgd it's
going to represent
just a black box neural network
so we're basically going to be training
a neural network to take as input data
and output a set of parameters such that
that set of parameters
generalizes well to new data points
um
so
in this case here is d train here is the
data point in d test
and we can train this with standard
supervised learning so we can take our
meta training data set
and
feed in the data into this uh into this
neural network have it produce a set of
parameters and train it such that with
those set of parameters it makes
accurate predictions
so
what it looks like for standard
supervised learning is we sample a task
we sample
um we have the training data set for
that task which produces phi and then we
train it such that this network 5 can
this network g with parameters phi can
accurately
predict labels based on that for that
task
um
yeah so you can also view kind of this
loss as
the
how well this set of parameters phi does
on the test set
and then from that standpoint you can
view this meta training objective as
something that has your model that takes
this input training data set produces a
set of parameters based on that training
data set
and then is trained such that that set
of parameters generalizes to a test data
point
and this optimization is done across all
of the tasks
so any clarification questions on how
this works
[Music]
yeah so you do this um this is kind of
what happens during training is you have
um like we have
we talked about before you have a
trained data set in a test data set for
each task
and you sample different tasks you pass
those into your model
that produces a set of parameters and
then you
evaluate the generalization performance
of that set of parameters
and then at test time
you no longer have any of the meta
training data set and you're given
a data set for a test task
um
this is kind of the trained data set for
this new task you pass that into the
model and that gives you a model that
generalizes for that test task
but you don't need any of the
metatrading data
for
um to do this at test time
my question is about the ti in the
bottom right of the site
sorry
yeah so this ti this is um a sum over
all of the tasks in your meta training
data set
okay
okay fine um
my next i have one more question um
[Music]
um
essentially i'm wondering conceptually
why we introduce fight eye as opposed to
treating this as a traditional learning
problem where
in addition to your uh x test you're
also priming the network with um the
support set that corresponds to
um
the support set for the test that
corresponds to the training example the
destiny example that you're getting that
makes sense
yeah so you could in some ways um
you don't necessarily need to
represent
phi separately um and we'll talk about a
situation where phi doesn't actually
correspond to a huge parameter vector in
a few slides
uh
yeah so you don't need to necessarily
represent that
in this case
in either case though you are taking in
the support set right here
um these are kind of your support data
points
and then passing in a new data point
here does that answer your question
um
[Music]
basically
maybe ask a question in a few slides if
it if a few slides ahead don't kind of
clarify it
um one important thing i will say is
that it's important that this phi i
depends on
i um because this is going to be
different for different tasks depending
on the training data set that you pass
them
um yes just wanted to kind of i saw
um or some technical things so like f
theta is uh you know what that predicts
like another neural network's private is
like a task network and then
when when we get those parameters do we
set that as the initial parameters of
the network of g and then we train g2 to
make those families optimal
or like so x like predicts y almost
perfectly and then do we do supervised
learning to get the predicted
fire eye to be the uh optimal fire i
kind of like that and then
back up like that and repeat
that's close although it's not quite
that complicated um you basically have a
neural network that takes as input the
trained data set and outputs the
parameters for
this other network
you don't need to do any additional
training on phi
the what you'll be doing here is the
basically it outputs the parameters of
another neural network that is um that
corresponds to this neural network right
here and then the
when you do this kind of meta training
optimization you're optimizing over the
parameters theta of this model right
here
uh and you're basically optimizing this
model so that
it can effectively produce parameters
for these different tasks
okay so i guess like the gradients would
kind of be
passing straight directly through theta
rather than too far so the gradients
will pass straight directly through phi
into theta
uh okay and then for phi i does that uh
have to be the same for all tasks or
like i'm guessing like that has to mean
like whatever task we have like it has
to be the same architecture of your
network
um
that g would be yeah so in this case you
would want it to probably have the same
neural network to you for the same
architecture for different tasks uh
and yeah this will
but you'll have different parameters of
that architecture for different tasks
[Music]
hey so um judging by what you said it
seems like you distinguish we're
distinguishing between the uh meta
parameters i guess theta and the
attached specific parameters that are
output by the player which is phi i
right
um i was wondering so simply the whole
[Music]
yeah so when you compute the loss with
regard to um theta of this objective for
example what you'll get is you'll get
something that correspond corresponds to
basically dl d phi i
and then you'll get d phi i
uh
d
theta uh just with the chain rule
that will allow you to get gradients for
theta for each of the tasks and you'll
average those across all of the tests
yeah so while training this model would
you
uh run it in all the tasks and then
update the gradients or would you wait
for one task to converge first like how
would you do that
yeah so you'll in practice you'll sample
a batch of tasks and
um
and i kind of a mini batch of tasks and
you'll average across that so actually
i'll just go through the algorithm right
now so what this looks like
is you'll sample one task or
a mini batch of tasks
you will
sample disjoint data sets
d train and detest from the data that
you have for that task so maybe the data
that you have for this task looks like
something like this
then you'll basically put this into
a d train and a d-test
then you'll
compute by i
from the training data set
then you'll update the meta parameters
using basically the gradient with
respect to theta
um
evaluated when with respect to the how
well
i does at
predicting
new data points in the test
if you have just a single task that you
sampled then this gradient will just be
with that one task uh if you use a mini
batch of tasks then you'll basically
compute the gradient for each of these
tasks uh compute the meta gradient with
respect to the meta parameters data for
each of the tasks and use that to update
data
and then you'll iterate this process
iteratively updating theta based on the
task that you sample
yeah so my question is in in this
particular setting
the model is basically trying to learn
a kind of pattern matching right like
it's not really understanding what
really that image is all it's trying to
do is in the test set what is this
particular image closest to in the given
task training set right
it's not really trying to understand
what that image is or like what are the
deeper level features of that images
right it's just trying to match what is
it closest to its given training set
yeah so
when you have like kind of a like in
this case like a four-way classification
problem
then a kind of reasonable strategy is
just to find something that kind of
matches well does how does this like
image look like in comparison to each of
the examples in the train set um we'll
actually talk about approaches that
specifically try to do this uh kind of
matching process in a few lectures when
we talk about non-parametric metal
learners
um one thing that i'll emphasize is that
if you're doing classification this
strategy might work but if you have
regression tasks or motor control tasks
or something then kind of the general
principle of trying to take in a data
set and learn something from a data set
that generalizes
uh may be a little bit different than
the matching process that you just
described
right so just from my understanding
that's what we are trying to do right
like we are not really trying to get a
deeper understanding of what these
images are right we are just trying to
you know so we're just basically trying
to be able to generalize uh
be able to produce an image classifier
that can classify
among these four classes in this example
um we're not trying to
generalize beyond these four classes or
beyond what's in the training dataset
uh and then one more question before
are there any trade-offs besides
complexity if we wanted to
make finite robust permutations in the
support set
um
so basically you're saying that if you
basically change the order of the
examples in the training data set
um like can you are you're asking about
how you can make it robust to those
permutations yes
you could build a more complex model i
suppose but is there anything else that
you should think about
before jumping ahead and doing that
yeah so we'll we'll talk about that in
one or two slides
cool so um
one challenge that comes up with this
approach is that outputting like a lot
of neural network parameters doesn't
necessarily seem very scalable because
you have to have a neural network output
all of those parameters
uh and so one idea for approaching this
and this has actually been um one of the
more common ways to approach blockbox
adaptation approaches is to not output
all the parameters but only output some
of like the sufficient statistics that
you need
um and what this looks like is instead
of outputting a phi i
uh you instead
output this kind of
hidden vector h
uh and i'll use h because it's analogous
to the hidden state of our current
neural network
and this represents kind of contextual
task information
and then this neural network g
is going to be
uh basically a combination of
uh
of this contextual information h and
then some fixed parameters data tree
that are the same
for all of the different tasks
and so you may just have another normal
network uh that takes that has these
parameters data g and then also takes
input task specific information and uses
that to classify the
images in d-test
um
if you recall when we talked about
multi-task learning where we had this
vector zi that kind of
task encapsulates
information this is also kind of pretty
similar where this hi can capture
information about that task and tell you
what task you're trying to be performing
where theta g would then correspond to
the parameters of this network
um
yeah and then
in this case when you optimize over the
meta parameters you'll optimize both
over theta g as well as the parameters
of this network that produces hi
you may also have some amount of
parameter sharing where theta g may also
be kind of a part of this network on the
left
maybe like these encoder parameters
are also kind of the same as how you
encode
the
encode the input here and then you get
something that looks like a neural
network where it's just taking in data
points and then also taking the test
data point and making a prediction
okay and then kind of the the most
general form of this is something just a
model that takes as input the training
data set and the tested input and
produces the corresponding label
okay
now one natural question is what
architecture should we use for this
model f theta
um there's a few different kind of
approaches one is to use an lstm
or neural turing machine these are
basically different architectures that
incorporate some amount of memory into
the neural network
uh you could also use an architecture
that is feed forward it basically takes
his input each of the examples in the
feed forward network produces some um
some embedding r and then averages that
embedding r
to
uh and that r is kind of provided to
another network another feed forward
network that tells you information about
the task
i'm curious if anyone has thoughts on
why
a fee forward and averaging architecture
might be better than a recurrent neural
network
i think that the the memory of the
calcium recurrent model is most useful
when you have a bunch of temporally
displaced data and here you're not
necessarily
actually capturing any sort of uh notion
of temporality since it's just a bunch
of
data points
yeah so the the data that you're
receiving in a supervised learning
problem may not have um
they don't have any temporal structure
and then also as mentioned in the chat
uh
and also what was mentioning earlier
it doesn't matter what order these data
points are in uh and if you kind of
permute the ordering
then
the
you should get the same output right and
so this feed forward architecture is
actually permutation invariant for the
data this you'll get the same embedding
as a function of the different
permutations of the data and so that
encodes this um encodes this kind of
nature about most data sets that they
are permutation and variant
of course there is also data that has
sometimes has temporal structure and in
those cases things like rnns might be
better
um and then there's also other external
memory mechanisms people have used
temporal convolutions
uh and these kinds of architectures tend
to do uh have shown strong performance
on different problems uh so for example
this uh model that uses attention and
convolutions is able to get around 99
accuracy on five-way omniglot and around
97 accuracy on 20-way one-shot on the
flat
okay so pros and cons uh one benefit of
this approach is it's very expressive
it's also easy to combine with a variety
of learning problems
so we'll see
later in the course how you can combine
this with a reinforcement learning
problem
one downside is that it's
rnns and these architectures can be
fairly complex
and they also have to learn how to
process this data and learn from this
data
from scratch basically and so it could
be a challenging optimization problem
and you'll find in your homework that uh
it can be a bit finicky based on
different hyper parameters and different
choices although we'll hopefully provide
good hyper parameters so you don't need
to do too much searching
and as a result it tends to be fairly
data inefficient in terms of the amount
of metatrading data that it needs
and then on wednesday we'll talk about
what happens if we treat this as an
optimization problem
instead of kind of a black box neural
network problem
uh if people want to stick around and
ask more questions you're welcome to and
i'll answer them if not i'll see you all
on wednesday